ええええええ
me
思っております
今回は皆さんにちわ近い力なりと題しまして
皆さんに知識の
素晴らしい様のお伝えしたいと思います
あとはいっても僕はそんな知識があるわけでもありませんし
知識とか偉そうに語れる立場でもありません
ただ知識というものに人生を変えられた身として皆さんに改めてよ
父の素晴らしさをお伝えしたいのです
知識
これはあって困らない
その視点子です
知らない方がいいと言うようなら知らんぷりをすればいいですかっ
ところがクリスティかやっているぞ
周りの人にそんな知識どこですか
逆にさないでしょ
とよく言われるんですよ
皆さんフットサルって知ってますか
5人でやるスポーツ作監ちっちゃいがう
それくらいまあ指定中もいらっしゃらないでしょうか
でもクイズをやっていると
pivo ピクソアラっ子0 d
これフットサルの孤児者名前なんですけどこういうのも覚えられるんです
方向3名社の4月
新しいクラスメイト
なにやってるのを見たいな鑑賞中へ
ずっとしゃべって言われて
ポジションはピヴォなんというと向こうもこいつわかってるのかなと思ってみたのか
その後で感謝したんですね
愛へと共通の子っていうことがあったり
市況2試合があったりするだけで話が弾んだり
中になったり
背負って多々あると思うんです
知識は困難意外なところでも入れています
ん
そんな知識を持っている人というとみなさんどんなたのイメージでしょうか
何かについてとてもよく知っている人
あるいは幅広いジャンルについて知識を持っている人
ここへグラフを使って
その知識をの量を紹介したいと思います
こんな感じ
立谷地4-4
横が知識のチャーリーと思ってください
これは全部1
ケーキやと思ってください
でも普通の人は全部1じゃありません
こんな感じ
知識量が多いものの少ないん
色々あって平均するとだいたい1
これが普通の社長ください
それではさっき言った何かについてとてもよく知っていう人の方
これをようでスペシャリストと言います
草の人になりません
どうぞ理由
これ
何が一つで告げ意見もありますが
岡松
でもそれについては代表を受けないそんなのは
したりすっ
対してデー
いろんな知識を幅広く持って行っ
これを英語のシャーリーズに対してゼネラリストジェネラリストっていうのです
これもクイズおやつでしました
こんなん
何が一つ飛び抜けているというわけでありませんが
幅広いジャンルにおいて高い知識を持っています
皆さんはこの
スペシャリストと全然アリス等
どちらがいいと思いますか
8これ見比べてみるとスペシャリストよりゼネラリストの方が知識量は合計が多いん
じゃいけん
ねこれで僕はゼネラリストをしていく流れはですけど
堀江した理由があるんです
今日2番手にスピーチたーーー on
政治記事車
めっちゃないです潮位
そんな彼が面白いってい
テストの点数は試験時間比例しないと
パイスーの具合みたいな言ったりするん
確かに実感をかければかけるほど店員さんの言うけど
だんだん3組は歪んでいっ
なはなさんが予定謎
これはまあテストだけなんですって
イオン本当に使えると思うんです
もちろん今井という知識っっ
知識を増やすのに飽きる時間労力
それとえらいうち診療
みんなが知っているほどあるいはその知識を覚え始め後
多くの歩道を吸収したり
ビガーお知らせします
ただ
専門的になってリー
難しいなったりするとだんだんえらいうちの要点は減っていきます
さっき同じゼロからイチこれは非常に簡単
1からにちょっと難しいっ
にかあさんこれには大変な時間と労力がいります
だから足を動かすスペシャ行っ水ジェネラリストの方が合計が多かったんです
8う
いろいろ知識を学ぶそんなジェネラリスト
全リストは幅広い知識を持っているわけですがどんな風に住ん幅広い知識を得るの
でしょうか
ちょっと僕の反射したと思います
ここはそうかギっぽい性格で
勉強とか全然ファン2基サインん
それはシミとかゲームぞ
行くスマホでゲームするんですけど
あんまり一つのゲームなら鈴木しないんですねえ
いろんなゲームとか悪霊をやるんですん
すると
いろんな発見があってっ
新しい知識を得ないです
皆さんパズドラてしてますか
ます
パズラントあるんですん
ドラゴンズっていつに強いキャラは家にばっかり
アンヌ見せていただきます
モデルはエジプト c はの冥界のカリアンです
これ中学の時にパズドラ始めしました
他にも数え切れないほど資源が出てきます
そのはず等で覚えた神々の名前だ
今クイズねたまに出るんですよ
そういう時にしてるんです
知識ってどういう感じで
ためになんとか意外とわからない
と思うんです
たくさん知識を持っていて幅広い知識を持っていると
その相乗効果が得られてします
皆さんも勉強していて経験があるじゃないでしょうか
数学で店希望なってなんだこれと思っていると意外と物理の法則とかで
を積分するドン銅雀
visa japan と者
なっています
その薬のソースもいくつかないよと思っても
まだ10問で星の動きとか
カープの物質のお客
そういうふうに使えてくるんです
幅広い知識がお互いに影響しあって高めあ
こういうも j ライスとの土地だと思うんですよ
もちろんスペシャリスト
これも必ず必要です
何かのスペシャリストであることこれがその仕事をやったり
その分野その際生徒にいく上で
ふ化に期待ですね必要不可欠ですから
じゃあそのスペシャリストのズレ等リスト
どの柄役人の良い消化
これは理想の側です
青年時代は
知識を磨く時であり
老年は実践するときにあるん
これを今の左外前ありその話を知っておきたいと思います
学生時代は
ジェネラリスト知識を磨き幅広い知識を得る
そんなジェネラリストになる時であり
老年を盛ってからわー
何がのスペシャリストになるだけだと
将来どんな道に進むか分からない
そんな学生のうちはできるだけ幅広い知識
これをいるので jr となる
自分の地図に道が始まる
現在事が始まる
その時に
それについて追及する
小さいしてなる
これが大丈夫考えます
皆さんも
同じ事を追求し
たくさん死去減るシャーリーズの果実ですが
幅広い知識を得るそんなせアリストを目指してみてはいかがでしょうか
一番フェンスよあれございましたーーー